it really is about the mutual
relationship between the employer and
the employee one where the employee is
giving his or her talents and skills and
superpowers to the enterprise
and is gaining more than a paycheck is
gaining new skills and abilities and
connections and a portfolio of
experiences that serve them well today
and in this organization and as you
alluded to in the introductions that
serve them well no matter where they go
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
hello and welcome to another episode of
20 minute leaders today i am with julie
winkle giuliani the author of promotions
or so yesterday and help them grow or
watch them go
julie is a champion for workplace growth
and development and helps executives and
leaders optimize talented potential
within their organizations
one of inc magazine's top 100 speakers
she's the author of promotions or so
yesterday redefine career development
help employees thrive and the co-author
of the international bestseller help
them grow or watch them go career
conversations organizations need and
employees want translated into seven
languages
julie is a regular columnist for
training industry magazine and smart
brief and contributes articles on
leadership career development and
workplace trends to numerous
publications including the economist you
can keep up with julie through her blog
linkedin and twitter
we'll have a great time talking about
workplace career development
both from the
employee side from the person developing
their career but also from the employer
and the organization the personal
manager because this question of
development career development
especially
in you know the the age we're living in
at least in tech the great resignation
the this independence this idea that you
know we we can transition to different
careers we can hold many different
careers and have different opportunities
it presents new challenges to thinking
through growth and personal trajectories
and so um you've written an awesome book
about this promotions are so yesterday
and help them grow or watch them grow
watch them go and so obviously talking
also about retention enough said by me
julie before we even talk about this
specific thing
your passion for career development and
workplace management what is that about
you know i had the good fortune of
working for so many terrific leaders who
were just natural develop developers of
people throughout my career and i didn't
really hit a normal boss not even a bad
bus just a normal bus till i was about
and when i finally had this boss who
did not prioritize my development she
was perfectly lovely she was fine it
just that didn't matter to her it was
the word product
i realized what um a deal breaker that
was for me personally and for others in
the workplace um i was really
immobilized and and very unhappy had to
leave that job and find a a boss who was
committed to my growth and so
the rest of my career had really been
dedicated to
helping to build the kinds of leaders
who just naturally find themselves
developing those around them and those
are the leaders who in the long run are
most successful
so just to
make sure we have all the definitions on
the table and we're on the same page
this this difference in mindset between
the leader who
who
thinks about the development of the
people they're leading versus not work
how do you actually define that and how
do you how can one you know account for
that trait
like really boils down to it i mean you
use that the mindset word it really is a
mindset that prioritizes the growth of
people right alongside the performance
and the results and all of the business
related
outcomes that we grapple with day in and
day out
it really is about the mutual
relationship between the employer and
the employee one where the employee is
giving his or her talents and skills and
superpowers to the enterprise
and is gaining more than a paycheck is
gaining new skills and abilities and
connections and a portfolio of
experiences that serve them well today
and in this organization and as you
alluded to in the introductions that
serve them well no matter where they go
as they you know kind of take these
portable skills and experiences from
role to role
gig to gig whatever it might be that
defines their career
and so when we're talking about portable
skills things that can be translated to
different careers
you know at the end
does it clash with
with what we need people to be doing in
an organization because sometimes you
know you need somebody to
to do something very specific and that
is what the organization needs that is
what the person is being measured on
that is what the team is measured on
does that ever clash or collide with
this idea of developing portable skills
that will allow the person to personally
develop
well the good news is that organizations
and the workplace are changing quickly
enough to where we can't expect that
someone is going to just do the same
thing over and over again and not add to
their bag of tricks
anyone who's doing that any organization
that is doing that is going to find
itself falling far behind you know the
last couple of years have taught us just
how quickly everything can turn on a
dime yep and so
for an organization to ensure its
success over time
it needs to make sure that its people
are
being grown and developed over time
we all need to be looking around the
corner anticipating what's next and
laying the foundation for
um for for being able to remain relevant
and to thrive in those times so i would
say no it really doesn't clutch in that
the growth that i'm offering my
employees today
is helping our organization today and
tomorrow as well as helping that
individual
so tell me a little bit about what's
been happening you know in the workplace
this question of retention
and and how big of an issue is it that
companies should actually be concerned
about you know whether people are
thinking about staying or going how big
of an issue is this actually in the
workforce and how how big how much of an
impact is this having
it's huge it's it's absolutely huge uh
for most of the organizations with which
i'm working at least
i think probably organizations in
general i mean the great resignation
great is built right into the expression
um and whether you want to think of it
as
resignation or reshuffle i started early
on thinking of it more in terms of the
great reevaluation
it's a significant change for
organizations and leaders to contend
with
because employees throughout these past
couple of years they've had to confront
their
mortality they've had to deal with
family dynamics that they hadn't had to
grapple with before they've had the time
to pause and reevaluate their priorities
and in the process to determine that
they want a very different relationship
with work than they've had in the past
and for organizations it is a
significant opportunity we're really at
an inflection point where organizations
have the opportunity to shift how they
engage with employees
and to change the nature of that
contract that relationship in such a way
that folks are going to be willing to
return and be retained and continue to
contribute their talents to the
enterprise right and so now we're now
we're looking at
some you know if we're if i'm looking at
the the average worker and you know the
average team
you know how how does this actually
translate into the date today because
you know there are mechanisms for
companies to support the internal growth
of their of their employees some of
those are are trivial like promotions
right and you're able to take a person
and to tell them you've done a great job
i want to give you more responsibility
this is sort of the main mechanism i
think we've come we've distilled it to
but you're actually saying that this is
no longer you know enough
for today's reality what do you mean by
that
well for decades we have been completing
career development with promotions
though i think actions are anything but
trivial it is the default definition
that most people have when they think
about career development
and unfortunately you know with
organizations being hierarchies that
look like pyramids or pinheads with
flatter you know mid levels of
management with work getting done more
organically the opportunity to grow
through promotion
is limited to a very few number of
employees
and so we create mathematical and
possibility when we define career
development as promotions because
we can't ever give a promotion to
everybody who wants to grow
and so we have an opportunity right now
to expand the definition of career
development
and
in general and over the last decade or
so as i've been doing field research
with
hundreds of organizations in the us and
abroad
i've been able to kind of put my thumb
on the pulse of what careers and career
development means to people and there
are other dimensions you know it's
interesting the inuits have like 53 or
more words for that white stuff that we
call snow
and we just got one word for it and i
feel like with career development it's
been the same thing
the language of career development we've
only had the word promotion
but in the backs of people's minds they
know that there's more than that that
they want more than that that there are
more opportunities for them to grow than
just that and so i developed this
multi-dimensional career framework that
includes certainly that climb up the
corporate ladder because despite the
fact that the book is titled promotions
or so yesterday they are today they're
going to be tomorrow and that's just
part of the reality but the problem with
promotions is and that climb up the
corporate ladder it's completely out of
the control of managers and employees to
affect
and so that's been a lot of the
dissatisfaction
that's contributed to the retention
issues organizations are experiencing
right and so from what i'm what i'm
understanding is that
traditionally we thought of we we
started with this idea of promotions and
it quickly became conflated with this or
became a synonym for for personal growth
and and the
basic assumption here is that this is
contradict contradicting because you
only have so many promotions and as as
as you get higher in the latter year
there's less people on that level and so
you're limiting the personal growth but
that's contradicting to the whole
assumption that you want
every person to have personal growth and
i'm also hearing from you that it's not
necessarily
an intentional thing for corporates to
say we do not want our employees to have
personal growth obviously they do want
that and they understand that they want
their employees to be motivated and
engaged but it just sounds like that in
that we just didn't develop the right
mechanisms and leaders don't have the
right tools to make it happen right
see so well said michael absolutely
leaders and employees have been
operating with a very limited tool kit
you know use at that metaphor
so the in the book the the heart of the
book is this multi-dimensional career
framework these other seven dimensions
that managers and employees control that
they can that are in their sphere of
influence so things like contribution
and competence we grow a lot through
connection
confidence is a huge factor that can
grow
challenge contentment choice and then
the eighth dimension is still that climb
up the corporate ladder because that
there are times in our careers where
where that's appropriate but
if it's not available or if i'm not
ready for it at a particular time these
seven dimensions create a wide open
playing field for manager and employees
to work with to allow for growth in role
in the here and now
right so
we're in a team and we're in a corporate
and
you know we're looking for strategies in
order to
to
improve on
on my ability as a manager to
help my employees have better personal
development what are
how do i actually think through this
what what are some non-trivial things
that i need to
to question to ask or to do in order to
go to go on the right steps here
well the first thing is career
development personal growth all of that
is based in a relationship between the
manager and the employee right
and that relationship plays out through
conversation
so as leaders we need to be cultivating
an ongoing thread of dialogue with
people
victims this idea of development to
personal growth front of mind that's not
just that one and done
annual conversation where we talk about
your career and then tuck it away until
next year on this time
so that's one of the things we need to
as leaders we need to earn the right
to engage in something as
intimate as growth and development
really is to people
so that's sort of an ongoing thematic
responsibility or to do for managers to
consider
with that is the foundation then
probably the most important thing we
need to do is to help people start
thinking not about what they want to be
but about what they want to do because
so much of the challenge that we find
ourselves in right now is from the time
we're kids we think of work as what we
want to be when we grow up right we
think of titles and roles and that's
what success looks like and then we get
to the workplace
and managers reinforce that with where
do you see yourself in three to five
years it's all about wanna be
and that's what creates a limited
conversation between manager employee
so expanding the conversation is really
um non-trivial to use your expression
for sure
helping to shift the conversation from
what do i want to be to what do i want
to do
you know what does success look like to
you
what kind of challenges are you really
up for what kinds of technology your
clients or whatever you know the nature
of the work might be are you most
anxious to engage in what do you want to
accomplish look back on is your legacy
when we start talking about what people
want to do
that opens up so much possibility not
just for fulfillment and satisfaction
but for growth as well
so a lot of these things i i definitely
see how a
you know mid-level manager can can do
with their own teamwork a lot of it is
where we're talking about conversation
we're talking about
personal identity and and being able to
understand how to even communicate with
the different team members but now i'm
wondering on the corporate structure is
this something that is relevant to be
discussed on a on a strategic level for
corporate on on you know top-down
management from you know
in other words
who should be concerned with this and
and is it relevant up to the top levels
of the c-level executives or is this
really relevant mainly for the
mid-levels and low-level managers
see all of the above michael i would say
literally everyone so i'm working with
lots of organizations right now and
we're starting right in the c suite
working with senior most leaders to
shift their thinking to embrace
multi-dimensional approach to career
development to explore ways to elevate
these other dimensions to the the same
level as that climb up the corporate
ladder
and the
the plan is to then cascade that
messaging and that training and learning
throughout the organization to all
levels of managers and leaders in other
organizations i'm going in and with
frontline leaders just one division
one area doing some training and it's
it's stunning how a single manager
who's committed to expanding the
definition of career development and
engaging with people differently can
affect change just with their own group
they're affecting their culture the
satisfaction and even the retention of
their individual teams so i would say it
works you know both at the senior and
the really frontline levels of an
organization
are there times where this is just not
relevant
does it does that exist i mean can we
find some situations in which we say you
know what in this case personal
development maybe is not shouldn't be a
priority
you know it's really hard for me to
imagine
a set of circumstances
where development shouldn't be a
priority
if we're working with people people have
an innate need to grow
and organizations have the survival need
for people to grow and learn
so let's we're working with machines and
even their learning and growing around
us i can't imagine a set of
circumstances where we want to keep
people small and not expand their
capacity to contribute
right i mean i think i think that just
comes down to then the the basic
understanding here is that what we're
talking about is not
just the need for a person to advance
their career and to become and to move
up the ladder it's it's more of a you
know an instinct that we have a need for
us to be part of a community to be
fulfilled to to reach that to reach that
level of internal fulfillment and part
of it is through the people around us
then through our feeling that we are
developing personally whether that's
translated and moving up the corporate
ladder or maybe that's translated in us
getting better feedback from our
colleagues and and
seeing the impact that we're having on
the organization right and so i can
definitely definitely see that yeah your
point is really well taken we had done
some research to validate this framework
with 750 folks worldwide and what we
found was that all of these other
dimensions were more interesting to
people than that climb up the ladder
like when they had more words for snow
they could you know describe snow
differently than when it was just that
one word that we have done
so
when i think about the the research the
number one greatest interest in
aggregate was contribution
and that he just really speaks to we
want to give
and when we can grow and learn in that
process you talk about a win-win it
doesn't get better
i love that julie thank you so much this
was so enjoyable and i really loved it
i appreciate the time and the energy
and the insights and thank you very very
much
continue making a positive impact and
stay safe and stay healthy thank you
michael
[Music]